how do you have societies where you have
policies that encourage individual
individuals to express themselves to
find their best potential and put it
into action which socialistic societies
were never able to do capitalist
societies do do that but how do you then
marry that with the interest of finding
equity among people to find a balance
because we've had these excesses of
capitalism that are today being
challenged and questioned so finding
that balance I think is the next big
thing that societies all over the world
will have to deal with in the coming
couple of decades Society has a big role
to play there should be capacity
building there should be empowerment
amongst the citizens so that they come
and voice their opinions and not just
voice them also join the government in
actually making it happen and I think
the view of the citizens should be not
that they're confronting the elected
representatives or the government the
view should be that they are partaking
as equal stakeholders or other important
stakeholders in the governance process
so we look forward to that kind of
change or that kind of capacity building
amongst citizens to happen over the next
few years if we use technology in a
proper way then there are two very
important aspects of humanity which is
health and education and I can imagine
the farthest corner of let's Africa or
for that matter India villages being
treated medically or taught in terms of
education from another university maybe
in America maybe in England or Japan or
where you have